the toilet of the plastic army hundreds
of volunteers swarm this Mumbai beach
every weekend scratching away at the
sand to uncover the detritus of a
throwaway society can you believe one
year we've been doing this campaign one
year now we come back and it is so much
cleaner they've cleared 12 million
kilograms of plastic and still they find
more afros is the inspiration to you
you've been busy this morning already
helped launch sky ocean rescue and
mobilized the masses the next high tide
will come and take it never to come back
Bollywood stars have donated heavy
machinery but the war on plastic is
being fought largely with human graft
even the local schoolchildren have
joined the effort not because they have
to but because they want to the problem
was a plastic it is we will have to the
initiative come here and clean it up so
we are just clearing the mess that was
created by our parents
what they've achieved on this stretch of
beach is nothing short of a miracle but
hell isn't far away where they don't
clean the sea deposits layer upon layer
of plastic become a short distance up
the coast now and this is a plastic
beach just as bad as it was a year ago
the reason being that the creek that
flows from the center of mumbai carries
with it a steady stream of plastic and
while that goes on there's little
prospect of them being able to hold back
the plastic adjoined afros on a journey
to the source of the plastic five
thousand people live in this slum
they're overlooked by the authorities
and the streams are used as sewers can
you see this is the Kliq high tide comes
in the water comes in and it just washes
the past nobody can think this is
beautiful why do they throw plastic in
the water like this well there's no
garbage pickup here and no garbage
nobody tells them how to handle plastic
but residents are now being paid to
collect bags which are then sorted and
recycled waste that has a value is no
longer thrown away if this boy gets it
right he gets it right saying that I
will collect all this plastic he'll
handle our plan will be in safer hands
not from the sofa beach shows what can
be achieved now restored to a place
where lovers stroll and children play
but the Menace of plastic is never far
away
Thomas More Sky News Mumbai